[Musique]
oui
emmanuel macron potentielles cibles du
logiciel pegasus le chef de l'état
ferait partie des cibles dans le viseur
du maroc
s'il conteste rabat figurerait parmi les
pays qui auraient le plus utilisé
l'outil le parquet de paris ouvre une
enquête enquête qui fait suite à la
plainte déposée par le site mediapart
dont deux journalistes ont été visés
la france fait face à sa quatrième bague
et 18 mille cas de colis 19 ans 24
heures hausse record en croire olivier
véran auditionné cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale où le projet de
loi consacré aux nouvelles mesures
sanitaires est examinée après un avis
favorable du conseil d'état sous
conditions le gouvernement devrait
procéder à quelques ajustements
jean castex saisira le conseil
constitutionnel après l'adoption du
texte par le parlement
les tensions s'intensifient en
afghanistan le palais présidentiel à
kaboul a été ciblé ce matin par des tirs
de roquettes
une attaque revendiquée par des chais
qui s'est déroulé en pleine fête de
l'aïd el-kébir plusieurs responsables
s'étaient réunis autour du président à
cette occasion quelques heures plus tôt
le chef de l'état a choisi a ni accusé
les talibans de la boire aucune volonté
de paix malgré les affirmations
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue à vous si
vous nous rejoignez sur rt france si les
faits sont avérés ils sont évidemment
très grave
voici la réponse de l'elysée alors que
vient d'être révélé un potentiel
espionnage du maroc de l'un des
téléphones à des manuels macron selon
nos confrères du monde
une enquête est ouverte à paris pour
faire la lumière sur l'utilisation du
logiciel espion israélien
pegasus pour rappel à de très nombreux
journalistes opposants et militants des
droits de l'homme ont été ciblés pour le
compte d'une dizaine de gouvernement
enjoint tout de suite 4 ap ethnique
devant l'elysée pour plus de précisions
bonsoir katia à leur nouveau
rebondissement dans cette affaire après
les premières révélations sur
l'espionnage des journalistes le
consortium d'investigation a déterminé
que de nombreux politiques français
avaient été ciblés notamment le
président de la république emmanuel
macron et edouard philippe
alors premier ministre à l'époque
et oui en effet c'est une bombe qui
explose en deux temps en effet hier des
révélations surgies expliquant que 50000
personnes avaient été la cible
potentielle d'un logiciel espion
pegasus de la société israélienne et
nassau et ce pour le compte d'une
dizaine d'états l'arabie saoudite le
mexique ou encore les émirats arabes
unis et la dernière révélation choc
c'est que les numéros des manuels macro
et d'edouard philippe figurer sur cette
liste ainsi que ceux de 14 ministres en
exercice en 2019 il y avait par exemple
gérardin gérald darmanin ou encore bruno
le maire et par qui est bien car par qui
était-il et écouter potentiellement et
bien tout comme nos confrères
edwy plenel et lénaïc bredou de
mediapart par les services secrets
marocains le maroc aurait fait espionner
ou voulu faire espionner dix mille
personnes dont 1000 en france et sur
cette liste figurent également des
parlementaires de l'opposition comme
adria 80 ce député insoumis ou encore
robert ménard le maire de béziers et
même alexandre benalla ses dires à
l'assemblée nationale cet après-midi 7
est évidemment le choc
jean castex que s'est vu poser la
question de cet espionnage au plus haut
sommet de l'état
interrogé dans l'hémicycle il a expliqué
que des investigations qui n'avait pas
abouti à ce stade avait été ordonnée
donc peu de clarté en ce moment de la
part du gouvernement
mais si cet espionnage était avérée cela
signifierait de graves problèmes
diplomatiques potentiel avec le maroc et
cela nous place aussi face à notre
impuissance au niveau des nouvelles
technologies du renseignement et
d'espionnage et pourtant les
journalistes alerte depuis plus de trois
ans sur la dangerosité de ce logiciel
pegasus je vous propose d'écouter des
réactions indignées de parlementaires
cet après midi à l'assemblée le
gouvernement israélien est très proche
de la société qui a mis en circulation
cette suite logicielle le gouvernement
israélien d'ailleurs et explique qu'il
vérifie les clients
de cette société privée certes privée
mais qui est sur le sol d'israël donc je
ne suis pas sûr que ce soit un imbroglio
bilatérales uniquement entre la france
et le maroc et je crois d'ailleurs
j'imagine que les services de
renseignement français travaillent avec
les services de renseignement marocains
donc ça ouvre des tas de questions il ya
deux choses quand d'alleuze que un pays
qui est pas un pays ennemi 1 nous
espionnent ça ça pose question
et puis l'autre chose c'est l'intrusion
dans nos téléphones portables par par
une dispositif qui est un dispositif on
ne sait pas par qui les contrôle et
comment à quoi ça sert c'est terrible
c'est naturellement un scandale
extrêmement choquant c'est une agression
qui est insupportable et que l'on doit
combattre il puis c'est aussi le signe
de la faiblesse de nos outils de
sécurité de protection des plus hauts
dirigeants français donc il faudra en
tirer toutes les conséquences alors la
société israélienne nso affirmé qu
emmanuel macron n'a jamais été une cible
ou n'a jamais été sélectionné comme une
cible par des clients de nso mais il ya
aussi une réponse des entreprises qui
sont plus promptes à réagir que des
politiques la filiale amazon web
services qui a disposé de serveurs
utilisés par nso groupe leur ont tout
simplement coupé l'accès à ces serveurs
c'était une partie importante de
l'infrastructure technique et de haine
et son groupe 4 ap ethnique en direct
depuis l'elysée merci beaucoup pour tout
ces précisions
on va continuer à parler de l'affairé
pegasus avec notre invité ce soir joseph
breham avocat au barreau de paris
bonsoir joseph bref merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors vous faites
partie de ces personnalités françaises
dont le téléphone n'a été
potentiellement ciblés par les autorités
marocaines à l'aide est de ce logiciel
espion pegasus qu'allez vous faire
la première chose c'est que je vais pas
partie des personnes potentiellement
ciblées puisque je ne suis pas sur la
liste
pas seulement sur la liste j'avertis des
personnes dont on sait qu'elles ont été
écoutés puisque j'ai donné mon mon
téléphone a investi qui a pu vérifier et
qui peut affirmer que au moins entre
septembre et décembre 2019 le maroc m'a
espionne et la deuxième chose c'est que
nous avons nous déposer d'été enfin je
vais déposer des plaintes ou plutôt mon
avocate un ami saïdi côté va déposer des
plaintes en mon nom et pour matin je
vais également déposé des plaintes au
nom de mes clients qui ont été ciblés un
certain nombre de plateaux au moins
contre enfin pour madame claude mangin
et puis peut-être un certain de
politique et canet comment est il
possible justement qu'à un président de
la république même un premier ministre
soit espérer de cette manière alors
comment c'est possible ça prouve au
moins que le maroc qui clamait neutre
notre meilleur allié est un allié que
l'on doit regarder avec beaucoup de
prudence et probablement même que l'on
devrait traiter un peu différemment ce
que je rappelle que jusqu'à présent la
france a toujours largement protégé dès
qu'il y avait des exactions les
autorités marocaines
lorsque l'on déposé plainte contre le
patron de la dst marocaine des services
de sécurité marocains là la france à
l'époque c'était la gauche mais la
droite a fait exactement la même chose
l'élève au rang de commandeur de la
légion d'honneur
donc bon ça trouve que jusqu'à présent
la france est protégé et là j'espère en
tout cas aujourd'hui que devant ces
violations extrêmement grain et cette
démonstration qu'en fait le maroc se
comporte comme le pire de nos ennemis et
bien cette fois ci enfin la france va
réagir et et mettra un terme à
l'impunité marocaine en france alors
qu'il risque quoi dans cette affaire cns
au groupe à l'initiative de ce logiciel
le gouvernement marocain comment comment
ça va se passer en fait au niveau
juridique au niveau juridique on peut
pas attaquer un état jeu
parlant la responsabilité pénale d'un
état c'est strictement impossible donc
en revanche pardon on peut attaquer des
personnes privées
ça peut être mais ça ça va être à la
justice de nous le dire
ça peut être le dirigeant des services
secrets marocains donc abdellatif
hammouchi ça peut être le ministre de
l'intérieur marocain
ça peut être telle ou telle personne ça
peut peut-être même être la personne du
roi même si a priori il ya une une
immunité pour le chef de l'état
le mais ça peut être également
effectivement l'entreprise mso les
dirigeants d'entreprises et mes sauts et
c'est un peut également être les membres
des services secrets israéliens qui très
probablement en tout cas on peut le
penser
filtre vérifie acquis et vaisseaux comme
des accords avec qui est ce que les
vaisseaux passent des contrats
donc voilà c'est a priori les trois les
trois types de deux responsables
potentiels
plus globalement plus globalement pardon
ce scandale d'espionnage appeler un
projet pegasus est ce qu'on peut parler
de violation des droits de l'homme s'est
pas encore parlé est une absolue
certitude c'est ce le la base des droits
de l'homme c'est que les individus prime
sur les les intérêts généraux et la base
de l'individu qu'est ce que c'est c'est
l'activité et ça à 7 cette arme de
guerre de cyberguerre c'est un moyen de
géo les définitivement la dignité des
personnes sans qu'il ne soit au courant
et sans qu'il ne puisse s'en prémunir
et c'est donc les conséquences les plus
graves possible jean-claude sur le sur
le plan des principes et puis ensuite
les conséquences pratico pratique c'est
à dire très probablement des opposants
humilié des opposants arrêtés des
opposants battus voire avoir éliminé etc
etc
donc c'est vraiment la pire excusez-moi
l'expression mais la pire des armes
possibles pour la cyberguerre est
d'ailleurs je pense que il faut
comprendre qu'en fait c'est zac de la
même façon qu'on a interdit les pierres
armes de guerre les armes à sous
munitions etc etc
eh bien on doit interdire aussi des
pires armes de cyberguerre
le seul moyen de nous prévenir
réellement de ceux de ce type d'actions
par des états voyous et ben c'est
d'interdire à dans nos démocraties
là où se trouve la compétence pour créer
ce type de logiciel d'interdire dans nos
démocraties la création de ce type de
logiciel pour qu'on puisse par exemple
le donc aujourd'hui la vraie question
c'est est-ce que les démocraties à mon
sens en tout cas est ce que les
démocraties vont prendre la mesure du
danger posé par ce type de logiciel et
vont purement et simplement les
interdire pas plus robin blement par le
biais d'un traité international
alors on le sert à l'espionnage est
monnaie courante entre les états est ce
que le fait d'espionner des
personnalités politiques ou publics ça
dépasse finalement le cadre de courant
de l'espionnage est ce que ça va trop
loin finalement de toute façon
l'espionnage et peut-être monnaies
courantes entre entre entre pays entre
états mais je crois pas qu'il soit
monnaies courantes d'aller espionner en
tout cas j'espère pas qu'il soit
monnaies courantes d'aller espionner de
façon ciblée tel ou tel opposants
politiques qui est réfugié dans un état
le sas et 1 2 c'est peut-être monnaies
courantes jean paré l'espionnage entre
états mais enfin je crois pas que
espionner le enfin violé l'intimité d'un
président en exercice d'un état allié
soit monnaie courante est en tout cas
j'espère par le donc voir les
répercussions je ne sais pas quoi vous
dire d'autre ça mettra emmanuel macron
services secrets français de les prendre
mais bien de de prendre des décisions
mais ses répercussions pourraient aller
assez loin ça pourrait être par exemple
expulser les diplomates français
le diplomate marocain en france ça
pourrait être tout bêtement seul
une réplique j'allais dire de ce
qu'avait fait le maroc en 2014 contre la
france ça pourrait être pire on coupe
tout relations franco judiciaire
judiciaire pas voir entre la france et
le maroc le ja il ya plein de réplique
possible il suffit que enfin et pour une
fois la france se décida à ne pas
accepter à ne pas tolérer les pierres
agissements ok merci beaucoup je rêve
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat au barreau
de paris
le variant delta continue sa progression
à vitesse éclair en france face à ce
rebond épidémique le gouvernement
s'active le projet de loi concernant les
nouvelles mesures sanitaires et validé
hier en conseil des ministres on était à
l'assemblée nationale le texte sera
débattu dès demain dans l'hémicycle
avant d'arriver au sénat jeudi
deux grands axes vaccination obligatoire
des soignants extension du pass
sanitaire cet après midi le premier
ministre a annoncé qu'il saisira le
conseil constitutionnel
je voudrais dire à la représentation
nationale que sur l'ensemble du texte
dont vous êtes désormais saisie je
saisirai le conseil constitutionnel
car n'en doutez pas notre objectif comme
toujours a été de prendre des mesures
proportionnées à la situation sanitaire
garantissant les libertés publiques
les scientifiques nous le dise si nous
fermions tous les établissements comme
nous l'avons fait pendant le confinement
pour tous les français l'impact
épidémique et sanitaire serait le même
que si nous fermions l'ensemble de ces
établissements pour les seuls non
vaccinés la vaccination est une chance
la vaccination est un droit mais ça peut
aussi devenir un devoir et même une
responsabilité
pas d'exception pas de passager
clandestin nous voulons du collectif du
collectif du collectif pour atteindre
l'immunité et se débarrasser du virus
il ne faut pas nous nous méprendre ce
n'est pas le pas sali dairou la liberté
la question c'est le passe à lithaire ou
le confinement des chevaux revendique
les attaques ciblées à kaboul ce matin
plusieurs roquettes ont été lancées à
proximité du palais présidentiel dans un
contexte de conflit armé entre les
forces afghanes et les talibans
les récents pourparlers entre les deux
parties ce week end dont une fois de
plus rien donné si on fait le point avec
hélas medjahed et les masques du en
pleine prière à l'occasion de l'aïd el
kébir tôt ce mardi matin
plusieurs roquettes survolent la zone
verte de kaboul et explose une zone
ultra fortifié qui abrite le palais
présidentiel et plusieurs ambassades
dont la mission de l'onu parmi les
fidèles
plusieurs hauts responsables afghans
dont le président ashraf ghani restant
impassible au son des explosions
une attaque qui semble réduire à néant
les espoirs d'un cessez le feu
et ce malgré l'appel à la trêve lancé ce
lundi par la communauté internationale
dont la france et l'allemagne
l'offensive des talibans entre en
contradiction directe avec leur soutien
affirmé un règlement négocié du conflit
et au processus de paix de doha
de son côté la russie qui craint que
l'avancée des insurgés en afghanistan ne
d
billy's la région assure que les
talibans sont prêts à un compromis
je sens et je vois non seulement par les
mots mais aussi par les intentions qui
s'exprime sous différentes formes qu'ils
sont prêts pour un compromis politique
mais de leur point de vue ce compromis
politique doit être présenté avec
dignité
après vingt ans la plus grande partie
des dirigeants talibans en a bien sûr
assez de la guerre et comprend qu'il
faut chercher des issues politiques pour
sortir de l'impasse actuelle
profitant du retrait progressif des
forces armées étrangères notamment
américaines
les talibans ont lancé une offensive
début mai une marche en avant qui leur
permet de conquérir de nombreux
territoires face à une armée afghane qui
ne fait pas le poids
les insurgés prétendent désormais
contrôler la majeure partie du
territoire
une avancée qui pousse des milliers
d'afghans à fuir c'est ma maison qui est
détruite plus de portes et fenêtres la
bombe a touché quatre maisons ici qui
ont détruit toute notre vaisselle tapis
et marchandises
nous avons deux morts et deux à trois
blessés j'étais blessé aussi à colonne
vertébrale notre vie est horrible quand
tu sais ce que c'est la guerre nous
fuyons avec nos biens et propriétés tout
en nous avons passé notre temps dans
d'autres endroits
après la guerre nous rentrerons dans
notre village j'ai été déplacées à cause
des troubles et de la guerre ils ont tué
et blessé des gens nous avons peur
ils disent que ce sera à nouveau la
guerre je déplace ma maison à cause de
la guerre si le conflit se calme on
rentre dans notre village sinon tous les
gens peur à la veille de l'aïd
comme vous le voyez les gens sont
déplacés certaines personnes sont au
village d'autres arabes par exemple nous
sommes tous des déplacés des familles
entières déplacés qui doivent vivre au
rythme des combats et qui sont
confrontés à une autre problématique
celle de la malnutrition notamment
d'après les nations unies 18 millions
d'afghans ont besoin d'une assistance
d'urgence dès janvier un appel pour
récolter près d'un milliard
demi de dollars dead avait été lancée
mais sept mois plus tard à peine un
tiers de la somme a été réunie
alors oui beaucoup espèrent enfin voir
les talibans et le gouvernement afghan
conclure un accord fin de l'interminable
suspense au pérou plus d'un mois et demi
après le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
l'autorité électorale a validé la
victoire de pedro castillo le candidat
de la gauche a remporté le scrutin avec
plus de 50% des voix à sa keiko fujimori
la candidate de la droite radicale
une annonce très attendue qui met fin à
des semaines de crise institutionnelle
france attise qu'évite ch
c'est un pedro castillo tout sourire est
accompagné de sa femme qui apparaît au
balcon du siège de son parti perd ou
libre et chers compatriotes j'ai le
coeur ouvert pour chacun d'entre vous
dans ma poitrine il n'y a pas de
rancoeur pas de différence comme il se
doit
nous sommes des compagnons et des frères
qui savent que le pérou est toujours
premier quelques minutes plus tôt le
candidat de la gauche radicale est
proclamé vainqueur de l'élection
présidentielle par le président du jury
national des élections
aujourd'hui nous sommes très heureux
parce que le peuple a gagné le pérou a
gagné les rêves de milliers de milliers
de paires vient en gagner aujourd'hui
nous célébrons parce que tout ce mois ci
nous sommes restés devant le jury des
élections nationales pour exiger que
notre vote soit respectée une annonce
qui vient clore des semaines de suspense
après un scrutin particulièrement serré
le 6 juin dernier lors du deuxième tour
de l'élection présidentielle pedro
castillo est déjà donné vainqueur avec
52 12 % des voix contre 49 87% des
suffrages à sa rivale la candidate de la
droite populiste keiko fujimori
mais la fille de l'ancien président
alberto fujimori qui purge une peine de
25 ans de prison pour corruption et
crime contre l'humanité conteste les
résultats et accuse de fraude son
adversaire
conséquence des semaines durant des
milliers de péruviens descendre dans les
rues manifestants pour l'un ou l'autre
des deux candidats à la présidentielle
peu avant l'annoncé des résultats
définitifs
keiko fujimori fait finalement volte
face et annonce qu'elle reconnaîtra la
victoire de son adversaire
je vais reconnaître les résultats car
c'est ce qu'exige la loi et la
constitution que j'ai juré de défendre
mais je ne me rendrais pas haut et les
fraudes ont été nommés why are in lille
j'appelle les péruviens à ne pas baisser
les bras et à mettre en oeuvre une
défense démocratique
le pérou a besoin de toutes les forces
sociales et politiques
unis dans la grande tâche d'arrêter le
communisme de défendre la liberté de la
presse et de préserver la démocratie
défendant la liberté de presse il
préfère voir la democracia keiko
fujimori faute d'immunité présidentielle
risquent désormais 30 ans de prison
visé par une enquête pour des
pots-de-vin présumés lors de ses
campagnes présidentielles de 2011 et
elle a déjà effectué 16 mois de
détention préventive
pedro castillo prendre à lui ses
fonctions le 28 juillet jour de
l'expiration du mandat du président
intérimaire francisco zagat ch'ti
[Musique]
retour en france le projet de loi qui
m'a été adopté ce mardi par le
gouvernement et ce malgré les nombreuses
manifestations des ong et militant
écologiste ces derniers mois des
organisations qui étaient rassemblés
aujourd'hui devant l'assemblée nationale
pour dénoncer le manque d'ambition de
cette loi un échec aussi bien écologique
social et démocratique selon s'ajouter à
ces recours de températures s'élevant
pour rien c'est une loi climat de
communication qui s'appelle loi climat
mais d'une manière abusive elle ne
répond pas à l'essentiel notamment la
question des forêts n'est pas dans la
loi climat alors que c'était un élément
régulateur du climat qui est essentiel
on voit que sur la question de
l'artificialisation des sols
rien n'est prévu que tous les problèmes
qui auraient pu être traités notamment
les économies d'énergie dans le bâtiment
la rénovation thermique tout ça est
repoussée aux calendes grecques
donc en fait de loi climat et il ne
reste que loi est plus plus climat en
fait on a ici une loi de pur affichage
qui ne nous permettra pas de tenir nos
objectifs
climatique et qui nous permettra surtout
pas de faire face aux pics climatique de
réchauffement que nous observons ces
dernières semaines et aux événements
dramatiques qui sont liés aujourd'hui il
est important de régler le problème un
différents problèmes d'une part nos
émissions de co2 l'urgence on le voit
aujourd'hui en allemagne en belgique
avec les les pluies diluviennes
créé par les dom de chaleur peut
disserter sur le sujet mais c'est pas la
question c'est vrai un vrai un grès
l'urgence à traiter ce souci-là et mais
réelle urgence à stopper net nos
émissions de gaz carbonique
en fait il aurait fallu faire ce que les
150 citoyens de la convention citoyenne
sur le climat avait avait demandé à
faire c'est à dire qu'il ya eu ces 150
citoyens qui ont travaillé pendant des
mois pour formuler un certain nombre de
propositions ils ont formulé à la fin
cent quarante neuf propositions dans
tous les domaines dans le domaine des
transports dans le domaine de
l'alimentation dans le domaine de la
production de biens dans le dans le
domaine de la rénovation des bâtiments
et si on avait adopté ses 149
propositions là on pourrait dire qu'on
commence à transformer sérieusement la
société mais aujourd'hui on est très
loin de tout ça la plupart de ces
mesures elles ont été encore une fois
soit repoussée aux calendes grecques
soient vidées de leur substance
et aujourd'hui ce n'est pas cette loi
qui va permettre à la france de se
retrouver sur une sur une trajectoire
compatible avec l'accord de paris un
projet doit critiquer on viens de
l'entendre mais pour le gouvernement
cette loi doit permettre de faire entrer
l'écologie dans la vie des gens
consommation transports logement
alimentation ou encore justice
explications en images
ans
là
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci à tous de l'avoir suivi prochain
point sur l'actualité dans une trentaine
de minutes
restez bien avec nous tout à l'heure
[Musique]
la grande bretagne a donc eu cinq ans
pour se préparer cinq ans de psychodrame
50 négociations politiques
est-ce qu'elle était prête le 31
décembre pour redevenir une île réponse
par du moment où le royaume uni avait
décidé de quitter l'union européenne il
ne pouvait plus continuer de bénéficier
de ses droits équivalents à si vous êtes
dans l'europe pas dans l'europe
vis-à-vis des 27 états autres c'est
juste quelque chose d'inconcevable
l'angleterre 20 perd gros là nos amis
britanniques ont fait un choix en 2016
qui est un choix qui je pense va
impacter l'économie profondément sur les
prochaines années et va impacter des
générations les choses sont en train de
se caler de se mettre en place
est ce que les choses sont totalement
fluide réponse est non
[Musique]